[拍手]
[音楽]
ええええええ
はぁ
[音楽]
[拍手]
あれ
皆さんビックリしましたか
そうですよねー
え
なんでこの人急に口からトランプ出したのえーどういうことを
ここテックザよね今から的なでもするのと何かしら
違和感を感じた方が多かったんじゃないでしょうか
そうその違和感やもや村がこの後私が話をする内容のカギとなってくるので必ず覚えて
ください
この
違和感を欠いた原因がいくつかあると思うんですけど
パッとすぐわかることとしてあれこの人って
カーブの研究者じゃなかったっけほら実験器具も用意して白衣まできちゃってさぁ
でパンフレットにも書いてんじゃん
でも
私が手品をしないなんて誰が決めたんですか
それは今あなたが持っている情報や価値観
経験則からあなたが勝手に決めたことなんですよね
そうよそうした未来とのギャップがあったから違和感を感じたんです
じゃあもし皆さんが私のことをはじめからマジ子なんだと知ってたらどうでしょうか
おそらく大半の方がイヤーマンションだけあって面白いとジェネシスなぁ
で
思ったんじゃないですか
そう人はあらかじめ情報が無い時に突発的に物事が起きると急に不安になるんですよね
それがサブタイトルにもある見慣れないもの情報ないもの得体の知れないもの
そういう風のはものに対する拒絶しにってやつです
それではこの拒絶し2-紐解きを始めましょう
人は物事や事象に対して何かしらのポジティブなイメージとネガティブなイメージが
あります
この点線で囲まれた範囲内のイメージでは
まあいっかとあまり深く考えたり行動に移したりすることはないです
でもある一線を越えた時から急にエンジンがかかったかのように人は動き出します
当然その逆もあり断固として拒絶する
そういうことも生じます
そうこのラインをいかにコントロールして超えるかであなたたちの人生が大きく左右さ
れるんですよ
結論から言うと実はこういう風なマインドセットにしちゃえばいいんですよねそう
これならエンジンかけることが簡単なりますよね
いやー分かりやすい具体例から紹介しましょう
こちらにを農家映った3枚の写真があります
どれも可愛いを脳がつった素敵な写真ですね
この女の子たち雰囲気や髪型タイプ
全部違うと思います
でも実はこの7個
全員同一の人物なんですよ
そう
こんな木雰囲気を変えると一般的には自分自身でも皆いなくて違和感を感じると思うん
ですけど
この女の子はこれを楽しんでます
そう一つヒントが出ましたね
以下に大いに楽しむ心を持てるかなんですよ
こんな経験ないですか
服装や髪型を自分は変えてしっくりきていないけどでも友達たちからはすごく似合っ
てるよって言われたりすることが
でも12ヶ月もするとそういう自分にも見慣れてくると思うんですよね
そう髪型や服装自分の行動にしても
自分はこういう人間なんだ
というに頭の枠や定義づけを知らないうちにしてしまっているんですよね
こういう風な価値の決めつけ方を最近ではパラダイムという風な言葉に置き換えたり
するんですけど
でもこの違和感や親村の根本的な正体っていうものを私は次のように考えています
それは
サブリミナル効果です
これは存在するかどうかは分かりません
でも意識と潜在意識の境界線沿いよりも少し潜在意識のほうにあるのではないかと言わ
れています
特に近く的な部分に対しては
つまり人間の五感だけでなく
それらが複合的に生じた時間感覚だとか
空間感覚だとかあらゆる感覚器官を通して何かしら問いかけてくるような
そういうふうな
この感覚これが
6山や違和感の正体であり時には
いやね悪寒がするなどの第六感的なものとして
これも人間動物ので奉納なんだと思うんですよね
じゃあこの本能がどのようにして生じているのか認識して理解することであなたは常に
拒絶を受けることができるようになるでしょう
こちらに私のこれまでの代表的な敬意を示します
高校まではいろんなスポーツの大会に出て優勝したり全国を得たりしてました
でも大学に入ってから本格的に手品を始めて大きく変わりました
そうこれまでは勝つ
だから楽しい
これだったんですよねそう私もこの楽しいがエンジンの下であったんですよ
でもこのエンジンの飼い方しか知らなかった
そ大学に入って手品をはじめようになってからこの手品の性質上
楽しいか当たり前になったんですよね
この楽しいが当たり前になるとなぜかずっと幸せな気分になってくるんですよ
なんでこれ幸せな気分になるんだろうなってもう1回考えた時に
何も考えずに笑ってられる時がはそうなんじゃないかなってふと思いました
実は何事に対してもエンジンをかけるのはこっちだったんですよね
これがどのようにして実現できるのかお話します
私は手品を学ぶことで人生の中で大切なことを多く学びました
人に物事を伝えるプレゼン能力であったりだとか
即座な判断が必要なアドリブ能力
そして洗脳です
なんか洗脳で聞くとちょっと危なく着替えますよね
でもこの洗脳
そうこれこそがすべてを解決する重要の
ポイントなんですよ
占いや収去
先ほど話した自分自身への定義づけ
これも全部自己暗示なんですよね
しかもこの自己暗示っていうのは自動的なことを能動的に変えることにも使えるんです
よ
じゃあわかりやすくちょっとて品を通して提携してましょう
ここにトランプがありますね
じゃあこのトランプ
混ぜていただいてもよろしいですか
っていうこういうフレーズを聞くと思うんですけど
もしとらん4パって出して混ぜてっていうとまあ意味不明ですけど当然トランプでこれ
手品をする長屋とお客さんは
混ぜてくれるわけですよね
そうこれなんですよ
これ本当は手品師がトランプを混ぜさせているのに本人は自分でトランプを混ぜている
と錯覚するんですよね
なぜ錯覚するかというとよし
怪しくないかチェックしてるぞ
っていう風何かしらの本人の意思が大きく反映しているからなんです
そうこの何かしらの石をうまく付け足すことで
他人への自己暗示も簡単に成立するんですよ
そうこのようにしてこの拒絶っていう風なものを
エンジンに帰る仕掛けが簡単にできます
それでは最後にこの拒絶を切れてエンジンをかけると
どのようになるかお話しますね
リジェクトの拒絶の世界と号の園児の世界には目には見えない越えられない国境が存在
します
例えば嫌いな人とはあまり積極的に交流したくないですよね
そう今まで関わって来なかったこの拒絶物
この拒絶物が集団であなたの中に入ってきたらそれはすべて新しいアイディアと概念を
与えるでしょう
そうもうお分かりですよね
この拒絶心理を制御することによってこの拒絶物があなた自身の心の中に革命を起こし
新しい糧となりより創造的な未来をあなた自身が作ることができるようになる
これをよしとするかどうかは人次第です
でもこれに蓋をするのか
扉を開けるのかさてあなたはどちらの人生を選びますか
[音楽]
[拍手]